des cartons par dizaines qu'il faut
trier et vider des mortiers accabler les
onze artificiers sont sur le pont depuis
9h30 ce vendredi matin le point final de
cinq mois de préparation
or on parle le nombre de lignes de
produits donc généralement on a là on a
une centaine de lignes ce qui fait pour
250 300 produits mais pas fait parce que
les produits qui font 25 30 ou 100 coups
ou les choses quant à nous il ya du
matériel
la discussion de fond avec les mérites
généralement début février et ensuite va
ça il ya des échanges pour savoir les
thèmes qu'elles sont un veau donc on en
est sûr deux mois et demi trois mois
cette année plaisir et les
clayes-sous-bois vont célébrer la
chanson française
une création de la société au rythme de
la musique et des lasers avec au coeur
du dispositif le château de plaisir pas
plus que ça mais tu m'as verse la 95è la
semaine vous pourrez tout de suite ça
vous serez pas emmerder on utilise des
gros calibres mais en toute sécurité
avec le château effectivement qui nous
protège le public mais bon on fait quand
même attention on profite aussi du site
on essaie d'inventer en fonction du site
que l'on a on n'a pas toujours des trucs
sympathiques mais là qu'on en profite du
château on peut jouer avec les arbres
l'aller on peut jouer que le château la
façade montage câblage test les
artificiers seront à pied d'oeuvre toute
la soirée premier feu tiré à 23 heures